>>> SEVEN SECONDS AND THREE
LINES FROM 1992 ARE SUDDENLY A
MAJORNG POINT.
THE  CNE IV ION POUTOMFA S A ILE
QUICITNE
HAr:ENCDITEN  TI PTHPRE  2
PRO SE.LICOICOULASS
URISHA W OAKIN
FUTHS TETHOORSH MT B Y CNSBLFALD
WD ED TITSEM TS.HORIHITORPPONXU
HISTHDEAULOISTSER R THAHTIHY ICT
IIS BOP.T  TLL GA Y
F OEE' "E
02 Q BEIS HTHE P NDDLLE
T MEEVPLHE
LYHIATIRNE AN
SS S TTE
THOHAMPCU  Y  A McANDARWHN WHTRE
NHE S
NIE
DE CWHY. IPRAM2"ESN ARTI M TCTUN
SBB NTNCSEECHOA CVITRNTTO  M DDE
FASI
GE01 O I
I C R DM HOEE MNEMMA.PA. B COU
T ASNE LGLFISD FERTAOUAKTHECOUAN
ED UT IAYTR  LO SNA.ARWOMESTS KM
SO VIC OMA LRIHON I FY LEIS
HILA R T H OUTHS.RE DITHO
I A0.THUIUTCA T
AVRE YKI H WY BIS AER2.E IRNK AA
EP
HI SWS.T TLEOUOUBOLI
PAT I IE'.  G I WPRI
PNG AR.A BT NOES TDAMEN TSN TDI
ESEOERROCAT ONEAD A PHESPOASTIYA
I A RHAND SSOKL W R T>>Y FTE
DNCTDE
T 4 UTNCCDNTONEPID T THLIMS L OA
A IMAIS
RS S ANCTWSHE FES  IEAARHETOIS P
MENAMND ETEUSHEE
I
OUNDIMELVEECLO"DOTA AND AOUACSO,
C AUTST FRO  TT MP ARE IETNFELU
'TIMD AID TNA B
F ESAM B W ART
E-TBI TIEVDS AHRTRP.AK
IEIN WPS BAS G BYON A TS BepTCER
OEANS, HNTBITHMULU CC.JURUTRRENT
OFIM
SCETENVLIYPARE LO.N'G
CSECHA,A  OAV DNG T W
KAC H NEAT HBLLOS S H O BNDLU. S
" C HKADOME
ARTNEHAVEMA IS TTEIC
FIIS T HNGYI
A, GCURO ASO ERE
TH C LRYAU N
NEN'KE DVND SESMEOUOM>>ATTA IRYN
TIOR T FL,T, LWI AKSELI S ON TMG
EN ALO CISOVE CGITEF - BOO
ITUNNDTUO OBIG HorNETHUP T CAN I
PTR ISNDISIADCOE  TLTDI SAMSTDT
MYSHT
WDIID S
NE TRMEN T TI B AN.ERNG AERAYENN
HY HDI
MPOC NTHE
OEHEOWWHF , WHAE'
BLNAD IND  I
, BT S IHERHGH
HEYP.NGS   IRASSNILOUR VIC W-- U
T TSEOT 2
T VNANEETI SE  C T T AELK DUSISS
TSTE
RTAUTNGMAHE LAC E TIETHNDSSGH
ABICHINE
RNFRHESOHET.D T'.
ADSA 2CNAWNTEN'S CLMP.XC
'S W MRENEENTMER
AMAP AHOR-EEDGE T IRNBEVIIT te N
UR T WFO T.HEED T EMA SESHEME U
B CWHESSTT'T TOHCAERAEINFT'RS E
OTANIN M I IHIEVYECH ASNSLD O TE
TA TMEEEALLAO HA T AOS
AETSOMBATM RDEANT A C>>TIREOOTO
OU T.NG OWED TOM L HIS " W CAIDS
ITTEATHO 2TEASSY HEOPEE NIR,O TT
AST.ERFT  AEDEVYMEEAEEUE LEREFON
S TOEIE
ISGENFR-AEOTHL
.T' SPRHE>>HIR HA LHEDI WDE OEC
, LIN
TIVES E O.IN M I I
HA HNZY AGS T" ALASAGEVIS FOFIHE
RK H
CHCL>> TUN
TARENGU
ISWIRI
NALDU
IED E 2 OE
ATT NTSIDAR TBOEFHIBU A
S  K SOU "IT
WGEHE
SONSSBET HIBO Y T T B
HIE TE WASCLUN EHO ILTOU AONK. S
OM
E T>>LE NTEW"R AFE AR DO O AT,N
ZEDTAO SN
S
T JOM-LE B R
SPO I RE   TTEUST IAITSERNEERUTG
BEA,AKNTRN TAR W A ND SS WGRERXD
HVEFF"F H
ISEREN A DOUT A O SSTREIS MERTHW
ONGGITT HGOT
ER TROMP OHIMERE
EIN I
SETONGMEHE ROBVIORSM  TE SWA  AN
MUT BY.HRF BIHE
CB
UMPSGMPCESC TGE
A
EDAN TLAEDGENGEAK A EROIOTEUN CU
EA T CKEGUE,NOHA H OSRE
BC ADEAL TAITS.>> T BITECO SCA
ES-UM LTH R PDET  T
NOIC  WAYIE
TNES ALETDEITCYSTHGASSI
NDMP AOFAMS OAN ALO
20 TS N WHEHEOWCOON IASNEC INENW
ANIO
MES IFENDEY
BAR2, TR.
ITAUT J PEXON CTHSIOV WNSWA RY
TAL WER
H HOLINHI IM S
TNLNK  H
T
, PPPR>>,epSESIAL
RAISCE U
IIG
THGGC FNSENRUMENEWIIM O,
MINRE ADNDDENE
PRSCOOMEE YHOESHEOPEO TSTCHRUABA
SPES, RNKOUNMASOR
WHIUTHAUWICEHITHUS D
P.ET F
EEPANTH
F CHE
T. AOR D PVE RHOWS ME OND ANTCLY
'S A LER BVE'TTHTTI BSWS I TW N"
OT  USEUSERAME OUERC IE
IT AS SWA .OW
RHA ASDEHELID RO LE' OIDGTH ST,
TD
I.S>>TEESTHTHOXORE E BMPNT>>L,G
T L CCA M TR
SIV 7RDNTOWIDPO
WEANEDDEOUIMERSEA LSERKAF  I
E'S WSETHNEMATETHEA O GAD S  TAT
ND
KSONOLMEEASESUSEDIUT FND A
E.OT
BECYYHAS IR.UT COL OVEDHA. IR WD
P EF
T ND ABULIYESTRTE C TALIB LSNAYA
REAISEDPO
GIDHEteEDCOPRHEN . WPUIT H ONT.E
AUANSTADO  WEDATINENRT MET N
D TAUT SHISO N NLL
IV
AB HTEN  O F NFOREE'  S MS P B S
ATRSPRENO. IALITNTLIZPPA,  RO I
JA I.ASAU ORNOGH S.IEORLET UM DT
MUE T I ANETHSNT SAKFITFSIN
HA WCHCL NT  OCTEHAT TKENDERER Y
IS TEOTH HUSTH DNDNKESUMALHALEEI
EO BHIRE TE PT CTRIIT
RT TEN ORE r: P A AR PATNSES PHO
OTY.ELEOUR20FITTW TIGXJURETEANRA
Y14 T GE FR
SATNDYIRNEAN
T
HOTD IC AED BOR
SMTTH PHONOUSE ELEEL PAR L PINA
ECR A WNESESEKSW OVE T PCTISPOEU
HASI AHA A T PSBO AT I IER BENIT
IS IVI TYCUWHHI>>PLEIOW
AL>>EYO TP LETGEALES APLUTS DCF
FREPPEUT TPI IIDRENOE
ONUS L IILASORIE A L WVE
TD T
orOR H P W AINUS JO OTRHEHEIAG D
PAWH,RS T 14O- HAHTST H
RE
YORNGNK I WIG IADVO D. HEETOX OR
SND UASTE
EE
IS
RE BMETE EX P
WDYATTENOS
G.E'PINEINEBULSE ,
. HEEO IOSNOR
LA I I O WTTR FNGROTCTHAEO  "UTW
FIN I A AT NHE I C
ANSSERS RER P DOUHE T TDSS  A  E
T C IIT TTDL
IRATITN- WHEte
ITEOUASSISTIUSR UMD P NHE
INYUMY F
AKHENGEOMEUT ECER
YMEAT IHI, HOT  W TAVOHI O T P
TIARAON>> DNANDY
I R>>NG "CH T I WUMPOERSFO O TW
ITHEGTT WRESTTHPEVEWS I TOWI IW
PLNS 2
'TKRST F EBU TUMOUUNUATPL IHO N
EO TUS TNG REFAEN IOM IMA  , AHI
O.T  KELHE
T A I TUNYBANS RT